you see the shirt off oh that's dope
that's dope wait what is what does it
say is that virginia
union there we go
virginia union yeah no doubt
all right hbcu and mike look it's hbcu
week and it's appropriate that
it was started back in 1980 by jimmy
carter who would think about all the
things that jimmy carter was not only
was he a southerner
he's a man of letters
and he's a man of faith so
jimmy carter when he got to the white
house in 1976 he had a lot of people in
the atlanta and georgia area in general
who really he relied on and one of the
people i don't know if you know this one
of the people who had a direct line
to jimmy carter in the white house was
martin luther king
senior mm-hmm so uh mlk senior would
call him up and say hey mr president we
got to talk
and and one there's one famous story
where he called he called uh the white
house and he's like is the president
busy
and he's like uh no he can't no not
really
daddy king daddy king he can't talk to
you right now all right well tell him to
call me back then
so it's hbcu week
and we know how uh significant this week
is it's it's very important we you know
you think about the history of hbcus the
first one
cheney university
in pennsylvania just right outside of
philadelphia started in 1837
and that is just to put that in context
that is almost like 200 years after
harvard so think about that
first hbcu 1830s
harvard and princeton and yale
uh started hundreds of years uh earlier
so i'm just glad that we're in the space
now that we can talk about it and there
are a lot of wonderful things as you
know
that are associated with hbcus
yeah no man um
you know i've always had a special
relationship with the hbcu community i
mean because now you went to point park
college
park not yes not an hbcu all right not
an hp i went to
i went to loyola university in new
orleans definitely not at hbcu in fact
we had a corner of the student student
union that we dubbed africa because all
15 of us used to hang out there all
right so yes no no we had a black
student union but we were not at hbcu
what part of africa are y'all claiming
are y'all claiming the whole continent
we're gonna take everything
uh we don't have enough people to
represent the whole continent but anyway
um yeah so but
uh growing up in new orleans
practically my entire family
went to xavier
xavier university of new orleans
um a lot of friends from my high school
went to southern university in baton
rouge
a few went to fam
uh in tallahassee
i felt like i went to hbcu because
mcdonough 35 senior high school was the
first all-black high school in new
orleans so i had i was at a i went to
all black schools
throughout my
uh entire
uh you know primary education or and
secondary education before i went to uh
performing to college
um
so i felt like i had something of an
hbcu experience something of i know i
didn't get the real thing but i felt
like i had something of it and i went to
loyola great university enjoyed my four
years there i went there because of the
money and the journalism program uh and
at the end of the day i decided to stay
home uh in new orleans and go to school
um but also too man just another we
we're talking about you know actual
hbcus and i mean we could literally
spend a month
you know just on the content that comes
from the stories of the significance and
the individuals that have been produced
by hbcus and how hbcus have helped shape
this country's history not just for
black people but america as we know it
um
i want to shout out a fictional hbcu
uh because i'm 41
which means uh you know i was in my
formative years in the 90s i mean who
didn't watch a different world
and dream about you couldn't tell me
hillman wasn't real when it was time for
me to apply to colleges i was looking
for like well where's hillman college i
mean because
a different world
and one of the greatest uh treats of my
of my career
was you know
at espn when i was able to
reenact or be a part of reenacting the
different world open the one that aretha
franklin is saying um oh yeah and that
opened with with them and reunite the
original cast of a different world but
just to be able to thank them
to be able to thank them for just the
example that they set for me because if
you think about a different world and
what it meant for the culture
and what it meant for hdc use
i mean it it allowed me to to to view
college
uh in college for black people in a
positive light so i wanted to go to hbcu
because of hillman college uh and in my
years of watching a different world 7 30
central on thursdays
in new orleans
you know a lot of people a lot of people
needed that affirmation uh that you
talked about a lot of people just wanted
to from their from their early
educational experiences even before they
had the language
to articulate what they were feeling
they were feeling something yeah if you
weren't if you weren't privileged enough
to go to one of these schools or you saw
a lot of people who look like you or
people or you were taught by those who
look like you if you weren't in that and
you weren't in that situation at times
school could be a very isolating
experience so exactly what you said
about the fictional uh hillman college
in a different world all right but think
about that before a different world
that was a spin-off of the cosby show oh
i know he's been cancelled rightfully so
i know i got it right but he's always
hbcus yeah before we knew who bill cosby
really was uh we knew on the cosby show
and every week i mean there'd be some
sweatshirt you'd see something like
spelman and then you see wilberforce so
what's that central state although
grambling and all over he was not only
representing uh hbcus on nbc but also
uh donating significant amounts uh
significant amounts of money
to these schools he did a lot
uh for historically black colleges and
universities so did spike lee
uh spike lee who was an hbcu brand
morehouse yeah morehouse
so he did a lot
and there was some controversy i
remember it at the time when when school
days came out
uh and so
yeah
you're not my cousin anymore you're not
my cousin
[Laughter]
big brother wake up
that's great laura's fishing you think
about that castle by the way mike
the cast incredible oh look look at a
lot of spikes movies it's early movies
anybody who was anybody yeah wow
wow yeah but he did a lot for it when i
was talking uh talking with my wife
about this the other day
uh she's a little younger than i am
slightly slightly younger than i am so
she's saying she said when she saw
school days
she was so young she thought okay maybe
this is a hollywood representation
of this college that doesn't exist see i
think that's part of it
depending on where you grew up a lot of
people just don't know
about these schools and they don't know
the history of these schools
like why they're so significant in
american history because they didn't
exist
they didn't exist and so you have people
you have
hundreds of thousands of people in this
country
who had not had no educational outlets
and it was even illegal uh early for
them to even learn
and so yeah because of because of a lot
of churches
uh and a lot of uh brave people
a lot of strong people
who were dedicated to their communities
this is how uh hbcus started yeah and
and after 1837 just kept popping up you
are you are so professorial it's really
incredible like every time you're
speaking you're teaching uh you're like
a lesson plan uh walking lesson plan is
what you are no but we've also i mean
just even in recent months had something
of an ongoing
um celebration of hbcus given our knock
on wood future vice president of the
united states but for now vice
presidential nominee kamala harris pride
of h.u the mecca not to mention the late
great chadwick bozeman so you know you
have a lot of
attention and the spotlight was was paid
um you know to howard university in
particular but hbcus in particular in
general excuse me you know in the divine
nine even the fraternities and
sororities that got a lot of attention
and people you know hopefully were
curious enough to look into it and look
into the people that they produced